hey how's it going
I'm Jake this is Mike I and we are about
to stream some pub G this is the sequel
to our last week's stream where Mike
punched me in the face and I died other
things happened too but that was
definitely the highlight and my defense
my outright I don't you have no defense
let us know if chat are our mics are too
low or gameplays too loud whatever I'll
be adjusting that as we go and sickening
is last year I will be playing as well
so I won't be super responsive chat last
week you said last year last year oh man
okay it's gonna be long someone says we
doing this live oh yeah
we're doing this live first first
televised chicken dinner no I'm just
kidding not at all for us all of our of
our Denny's have been offline late at
night but we've been reporting them we
have proof yes but yeah because there's
not a pub G there's not enough pub G
streams on the internet we thought we'd
uh here's my character I'm beginning to
think the white shirt helps me stand out
from foliage which is always helpful and
especially well know the thing is people
see a bush and they see a little red
bush on top of that book yeah Linden
when the desert map comes out I'll just
look like I'm floating by tumbleweed
tumbleweed thank you I got a red shirt
too James I can't retrace our names
something yeah we should start okay I'm
gonna just describe thank you for
subscribing really helps us out and
we're gonna try to do this every week so
well we stream every week we're gonna
try to play pub G every week not every
year yeah I will see how this goes
someone says yo Phil is that your other
name no they're probably talking someone
else in the chat yep the only Anthropy
Emmanuel Paris's I don't like you guys I
don't like me much either so someone
like your shirt I know dope shirt my
dude thank you said Kendrick shirt no
just this damn
there's my second cup of coffee so I
should be ready all right I'm trying to
mute this very [ __ ] turn it down a
little bit
should I buy Pub to your groceries so I
can eat well if you buy pub Jean when
you get a chicken dinner buy groceries
well this guy - all right I got I'm
gonna go wireless with my mouse wait
there we go
man this mic really throws me off so
I'll just on screen with your table be
mad at me okay
northeast
all right oh she could go to rock around
the office I'm affectionately known as
the sheriff or peroxo uh yeah could make
good on that we couldn't that's way too
far uh schools right here you want to
land at the school nah not at all about
milta now a lot of people go there my
milk milta or here coast no lighthouses
okay all three a two ones go whoops
someone asks what you drinkin coffee
just coffee on alert coffee and cocaine
okay you don't get you don't get chicken
dinners buzz show me one sober chicken
dinner and I'll show you that's really
quiet now like 4:00 a.m. and I'll stir
that's like I can't hear my game play
what's that like that game play just
disappeared people to people think
they're going to that barn
I'm going to land on the south side near
the coast because they just dropped near
yeah yeah I'm kind of close to you
because well I met this playground back
here oh [ __ ] no I saw my shadow
I'm already hey I do that too all the
time when I'm landing Lego that's me
shadow see what weekend fine all right
got a shotgun you got a shotgun already
damn I don't think anybody came over
near me could go find them I guess now
before I worry too much about getting
everything I would like a gun they're
closer to you I'm okay just so you know
I'm not trying to scare you trying to
scare me I'm not trying to yeah I got a
handgun to you all right I got an m16
where are they they were on the
northwest side of the town got an UMP 44
UMP 900 I like the UMP a lot all right
sweet I've got it pretty much some
decent stuff I got a backpack to another
m16
that need that I don't mind doing this
m16 you guys should try a home match
just fists hell yeah we should I do want
your m16 very much I am do me just mark
the building on the map please all right
I took one of the story behind you since
there's other people here we know for a
fact uh-oh
I don't think I'm I think I'm lying sure
to not cook grenades Jake how far are we
from the sir just chirping immediately
first thing in the morning we're
positive we are yes where's it at
oh yeah let's get a car after we kill
these suckers where's the m16 I marked
it on the map Oh yellow yellow sweet
thank you I was right next to it I don't
know do you think they just booked it
they could still be inside somewhere did
he cook too much or something yeah I did
yeah well he didn't even know they cook
like I guess what's my primary took out
my whole team in one foul swoop all
right I'm set if you want to go I don't
have a vest but I can deal without it
all right should we just run hope we
find a car sure or boat maybe a boat
would be probably we have to go now
though yeah Oh cuz we got some ground to
cover
I'm kind of new you I don't see one over
this way I see one right here really yep
okay night I can't tell if you're
serious or not how's your armor I have a
motorcycle helmet that's all
someone says press K to kill yourself
nothing happened
yeah 16-bit blast proccesing was saying
he prefers to keep that person prefers
to keep doors open because I think a lot
of people develop habits of checking
houses anyway so if they think if they
see doors are open they just assume
people looted it whereas I think when
you first start playing you just are you
driving are you driving thing is the
mark a spot Mike and I like to kill
people
oh [ __ ] what do I go do we have enough
time to we have enough time let's get
like way around yeah come on you know
south no no no [ __ ] no actually the
flight the flight path was I think a lot
of people will be coming in from the
coast so I say we Beach at a lighthouse
maybe don't see the foot here we could
beach right here at blue okay I can then
go or is there a beach here these are
all cliffs I think yeah those are about
blue yeah and then we can go into these
houses and move in from there on the
rare occasions when I have to like
realign my hand on the keyboard this mic
is right in my face really annoying
there we go
yeah we're better I was playing you know
how Nick and I so I was playing in the
office a couple days ago and the circle
was more in the ocean than it was on
land when we were playing yeah and Nick
and I like park the boat outside and
waited we'd already I killed like five
people at this point surprisingly but I
was like outside the circle we just
following it in and we ended up dying
but I was playing again the other day
and there was someone trying the same
exact thing so I drove up to him with a
sniper rifle got into the passenger seat
shot him right in the head nice
gamespot should do an inside match of
pub G we actually want to we're trying
to figure out the logistics of doing
that because we want to be able to
communicate with other people and it's
kind of tough to communicate with people
in the bullpen around here someone asked
you how what you thought of Dunkirk it
was really good if you like Christopher
Nolan movies this is his most subtle
although there's definitely a big
structural Nolan II thing that he does
with the way he structures it which is
pretty obvious right from the start but
it really is anxiety inducing an intense
I don't think I'll ever watch it again
but it's fantastic Chevy your clips to
it dude I'm I got it we got a plan a
different PC in here this is like bad
like I don't know if anybody else is
seeing it but I am i donno if it's just
monitor what we could go onto the bridge
the bridge on the other side of it
it's always kind of lag Ewing they're
not driving the boat keep going
well now that's just a fly let's go
let's go off right here cuz that's the
flight path down there oh wait behind me
no no no life speech here at these
buildings I know there's like farmhouses
and [ __ ] [ __ ] how about right here at
this Eppley and then we could walk up to
these buildings
I almost got a chicken dinner over here
yesterday
have you guys improved this past week in
the game that remains to be seen you
know speech here speech it yeah and then
got there in the certain release
okay don't don't don't
dude I am really really lagging on my
monitor I don't know if it's showing up
on stream it didn't last week but it's
I'm not feeling good about it
some 762 in there what comes do you have
m16 we go no I would love a sight oh I
have a red dog I gotta put this on my
m16 soon let me uh put this on quick do
you dude everything I'm doing is like a
second behind I do not looking forward
to fighting alright I'll just take that
extra second into account okay fighting
people all right so we are in just hang
out at the shack for now yeah we might
as well go to those buildings get a
better yeah I don't want to hang out on
this Shack anything in there two sites
holographic sight yeah I'm gonna take
the holographic sight I was gonna read
dot MRIs a red dot what kind of using
I'm 16 and I um P yeah I was a Jeep well
I'm getting like too
all right you've got chicken dinner last
week with squads
we got whittled down on live not stream
no no yeah we recorded it we could maybe
we'll post it at some point but yeah
Jake me Nick margarita and Rob handler
he's third ever match we got a chicken
dinner he got a couple kills but it was
a cannon we got whittled down and then
just like survived toward the end right
we get in um you can just went away for
a circle see where it goes and just peel
out once we sure I'm actually getting
some lag to ones first personnel gonna
hit the game I think it's the next
update which is August 3rd don't quote
me on that though FPS looks more fun I'm
curious to play FPS just because like to
be honest I'd prefer FPS normally but I
feel like you have such an advantage in
third person that I don't want to like
well is that oh [ __ ] motorcycle let's
get out of these right here alright
nevermind it's two people I think yeah
as far as he didn't see me I was
look at that the grille of this Jeep
alright let's get you over what's he in
the deep my drive sure let's go
might as well across the fields right
now while we can go to pollute it or
actually go to here yeah it's not too
far but at least parking cover though
behind the building
alright there's probably people here
this was right on the flight path look
up Bang Bang Chitty Chitty Bang Bang
vehicle [ __ ] what was that what the [ __ ]
they just run right into our view oh oh
they're behind us they're wrecking the
door we just came through I'm getting
behind this bar Wow [ __ ] I got knocked
down he's down here he's gonna kill me
[ __ ] I missed him they were already here
oh nice
damn [ __ ] that ended fast
yeah it did let's go again just a
warm-up have you guys ever tried to
snipe the plane down instead of thing I
don't know there's one death
we need a death counter for this stream
series I know seriously I completely
missed him with my shotgun
I had him too I just [ __ ] it up
bench Amex is I really liked your
injustice reboot episode by the way
thank you I'm gonna get some crates
quick see if I get anything worthwhile I
probably won't what's in this one to get
like boots a long-sleeve black shirt I
might actually use that because I'm sick
of this white shirt all right red yep
all right see how we do all right so I
like this black shirt more don't stand
out as much as these guys with the ties
I probably stand out with my blue shirt
my hair doesn't do me any favors though
I could save up to 3000 and just change
what I look like but I refuse
it's quite pricey yeah yeah all right
we went the tunnels last week and in the
actual game this isn't a tunnel
obviously but it's pretty scary when
there's a lot of people down there close
quarters Jake I don't think we played
that last game too well
no we did not probably should have
waited for the circle to move again
so we just jumped off and we hey there's
a plane up there is that the plane we're
about to use do you see that maybe is
that where it hovers until all these
people get teleported up there to the
death trap probably there's someone
talking goober not gonna squad up with
two other people that we can't really
talk to that would be a disaster plus
you guys voices are too low someone else
are they're too loud I think we could
though they said the gameplay was too
loud I think that's why I'd turned it
down before but all right coming in from
the east again it's like the same flight
back all right milta
you want chickie you wanna go let's go
Milt I'll just get right into this [ __ ]
all right
three two go there gonna be a lot of
people here there's so many people
dropping faster than normal it looks
like they're going to the school though
as usual not wasting any time getting
there
I'm gonna aim for that big barn on the
northwest side to our right okay I see
the one I'm looking at I will aim there
too but I won't loot they'll let you
loot there yeah I mean just that over
the nearest water tower in general and
so we're gonna be a lot of people now
are there any people coming this way
it's gotta be right see you I don't
think everybody else came this far
Wow yeah no there's no one that's weird
all right
we're looking for us looks like there's
a car too or is that blown out that's
blown out find there's two-story house
next to the barn and check the barn then
there's no car in this garage okay guys
I got to go good stream hey thanks for
stopping by got a vest over here already
if you want one yeah one of my better
matches was last week actually when we
won I would say yeah you uh carried the
team for sure is the plane on fire you
know I've never really wondered why it
does that every time it starts is it
just like popping flares I don't know
just really badly animated jet trails
there's an early access game maybe I
don't know I need a backpack nothing up
here I did not get much up here I'm
gonna take this five five six in the off
chance that I find something
how much luck over here you check the
barn yeah I'm gonna check this blue roof
place I think we're in the circle it
looks like okay
we found an 8k here we go at a UMP
yeah backpack though I don't like tab
picking up things unless it's an in
someone else's inventory I feel so
exposed
alright I'm decent shape
I would love a backpack gunshots yeah
assuming to the north that's where looks
like a trails dropped what are they
gonna finish this game probably never I
didn't say that that's what some in the
chat said yeah yeah he said it's
supposed to be done before the end of
2017 we'll see if that happens
did alright I just lack of it bet here
we go alright I got a shock on a UMP I'm
in decent shape
I'll be on the lookout for a rifle for
ya sweet yeah I'm in decent shape we had
um PE check out the plane is on fire if
people spawn in while cooking a Molotov
I hear interesting
okay that makes sense or maybe because
they're already on fire from below oh
yeah we are kind of in the center circle
so let's take our time here I guess
closed doors behind you if you want to
yeah I mean stay on alert though because
it on I people usually don't you believe
milto along for too long I'm coming over
toward you
looks clear for now
what storage behind you you can and you
can so do it I'm too much of a hurry
can't be bothered with that yeah you're
gonna die
sweet
[ __ ]
[Music]
it sounds close
see you in the sky he just went over I
think the shadow is passed over I don't
know where the supply drop is though
present dropped it yeah
did you go on this big I don't know what
building that says
no I didn't check that diner looking
thing yes there's usually good [ __ ] here
there's a helmet get rid of my afro
first date I got a decent out of like
first aid stuff I like don't have any
yeah the frying pan
well the game be released on switch I
wish cover my face up
I don't worry bout your face I take five
five six ammo in case they find
something sure rifle
yeah no those are both nine mil that's
not smart
I'll take that
[ __ ] I don't know what you looted
all right um damn I hate I actually
don't like starting a mill circle as
much [ __ ] for time scope I would love to
find I know
any sort of rifle at this point would be
great closer there we go
skaar nice with the four time scopes not
bad
all right and I haven't been picking up
all the five five six am i thirsty
because I didn't have a rifle yet but
now I do
there we go there we go but this is my
primary slot sweet
I'm good shape left better arm to say I
have a four times yeah back level two
backpack here we go got an energy drink
put this on auto damn hopefully this
isn't a boring match until later on
oh I could've up to the roof see what I
can see damn that alright first aid
again I have a lot of first aid I don't
see anything right now I'm gonna get up
stairs to
UMP is one of my favorite weapons it's
really good at like most like meat
mid-range and close range okay um got a
frying pan so I feel a little safer that
a red dot no it's a foregrip can I use
don't happen if you don't jump off the
plane at the beginning you'll get kicked
out like at the bat around the end of
this the islands a lot of people wait
there until they drop because there's a
lot of it that's where the afk people
just died right away okay by getting
punched in the face well but you have to
imagine that afk people take a while to
uh land yeah yeah I've always thought
about doing that but I've never like had
the patience this guy rather just get it
yeah please be respectful in the chat
guys well I what's happened oh just some
name-calling
all right well I thought that was a
Carnegie night every time helmet car
with a K I always your car and I get
freaked out that someone's coming
level two baths all right I'm gonna move
somewhere else I guess I see nothing
all right I thought dropping in here
would be much more like I know I thought
it'd be more exciting
I'll see anybody I'm pretty like well
set you want to move somewhere else let
me check the map quick yeah we are right
in the center why is that blue here and
put [ __ ] where he's [ __ ] around all
right um I found an m16 I'm gonna take
it we'll move to the other side of town
though at least like up here get out of
milta yeah she's gonna check the top
level of this dang it
see he's worth it all right we'll really
go to the north side yeah I don't know
circles closing in now we could wait but
at least I'm gonna move for the west
side of town anyway I have a holographic
sight I already have one and a force
have an eight-time scope nice I'm just
kidding I know all right sweet oh I
shouldn't jump that I want to move over
to the west side of town yeah did you
mark it go that barn for now yellow
someone else is there any game like this
on Xbox one no not yet but hopefully
this comes soon so there will be a game
like this I know ps4 owners have h1g
that's on ps4 a h1z1 wears only on ps3 I
don't think it's on ps4 I could be very
wrong though maybe as the chat this game
just have one big map yes it does
however the they're working on a second
desert map which is supposed to be
soonish I think mm-hmm well they're
working on a Mediterranean map as well
those are ones the next one
all right don't see anything all right
well I will drop into a crazy area next
match to make up for this once we win
all right where's the fight I know I
have no idea where the fight is we're
hoping we'd land in it the gate this
match will most likely end in the
military base possibly I'll holla see
where this goes right now
[ __ ] the center I mean it's good I guess
for us but it's not really fun to watch
when he is on ps4 oh nice cool what's
the red circle one of my better is
getting bombed out of there where is it
right now good we can maybe see that
from here there are too many hills all
right let's go to that house over there
I just want to be in Milton when people
start pouring in yeah let's go for that
one up on the hill there's a better
sight line let's check this one first
doors closed but that doesn't always
mean anything
stay spread out a little bit I remember
dying here okay so this is kind of right
on the flight path but people probably
have moved since then yeah we got here a
few times upstairs quick telling us we
should go to the red area on the mend
looks clear up here for now close the
door behind me
cool
yeah nothing here either oh man this
roof is really exposed to that Hill I'm
gonna get out of here oh it's all them
in buildings and stuff generated
randomly or are they the same each game
oh damn they are the same each game
uh-oh this is not good though all right
should we move to the maps the same yeah
the loot drops the bombings and the
flight path at random you haven't got
the hill sure when did that haven't
there been a bunch of mods like this
game already yes there have this game
was originally a mod yeah battle royale
it was a battle royale on ARMA 2 and
then moved ARMA 3 and then Brennen green
or player known went over to help
consult on h1z1 king of the kill mode
which is this gunshots but this was
originally a mod for dayz and then when
Daisy went standalone this moved to ARMA
3 really weird history but the dude
friend green like didn't make games
before he made the first battle royale
not the real McCoy says when you gonna
carry your team to greatness I'm feeling
good about this game I always get like I
don't like I like having a warm up at
the beginning we're actually fighting
though like I always do really well when
I'm actually I figured we would that's
why we dropped in to like go onto that
flight path yeah all right oh yeah check
these rooms oh no it's a bush sorry are
you in the roof yeah
yeah I don't see [ __ ] have you tried the
zombie mod no we haven't checked the
zombie mode on this it seems pretty cool
but I think they're zombies mode on make
sure they're nothing about Daisy well
there's a zombie vote on this I'm a test
server I'll getcha Ivan played much in
the test servers I've played it all on
them okay
I see nothing zombie mode needs some art
yeah that's kind of what I heard
Supply Drop coming in
go check that out
I don't know if it has dropped its [ __ ]
off yet if it drops in milta I'm worried
about people coming over this hill yeah
cuz we're kind of exposed to that but
that I don't think that would happen the
fly path was yeah they could 43 people
left
not a single soul in sight could move
somewhere else I'm gonna go inside quick
because I don't like this waiting for
the first shot yeah
um I'm gonna take a coffee break quick
let's see what is going on I circled
moving but not fast enough
could we move somewhere else for now I
guess uh this place is decent I guess
but yeah someone mentioned the
lumberyard is ever here I think yeah it
was the lumberyard so it's recommend
going there now should we well i we have
no idea where the circles gonna go see
where the circle goes that's not a bad
place so that's kind of on top that one
easy to defend oh that is close yeah
ringing let's go I'm getting bored I
want to kill you whoever you are
[Music]
it sounds like it's southeast the
tiniest windows in the world to look out
right now I know
which had a better helmet and vest okay
what's the circle looking like probably
okay now yeah but I still want to move
car coming this way we're come from the
south it looks like it's gonna come
right for this building really yep we're
at it's driving past this actually
demonstratin past it's also not the
south continue down the right yes from
the south
oh you were just within the south and
then move that way gotcha okay yeah
let's move somewhere cuz yeah if we
weren't streaming this and I wanted to
just camp out here I might but kind of
want to get on the edge of the circle
more want to go back to the other one
we're at right down the hill sure or we
know that we can go to that octagon no
bad idea I think I don't want to hang
out here anymore though they should move
the death counter from the game would
make it crazy that would be I think
there's a new donor parked in front of
it or maybe that's a bush in front of
yellow there's gonna be people coming
down here like any minute I don't know
why like down this hill
that's you running around right okay
Jesus all right are we going there what
else we wanted to I mean I'd we could
hang out here I just don't want to I'm
not patient enough right now
I don't see anyone I think we should
stay here though
alright whatever
let's see where the soul will we'll make
the next thing right from the beginning
I don't want to get on that roof that
roof it exposes [ __ ] and we don't pro no
gunshots where is he do you know where
now no idea we're close though
[Music]
sort of out in the open milta we have a
really good angle on gate I feel like I
hear footsteps okay behind us on the
hill way up on top of the hill from me
it's from both of us it's like directly
north at like 15 10 maybe I'm gonna get
inside all right
way up there yeah I don't there don't
take a shot until you have a really good
shot I mean I'm sure you could hit him
but don't give away our position because
we're actually a good position - this
hill but at least we have cover is he
still there yeah he's still up there
we're at I mean he hasn't moved oh now
he's out of sight okay yeah there's
gonna shot scumming okay I'm sure the
military base layer yeah do you want
Lana military base next game if it makes
sense
yeah if we can rather not for just let
you up this window is huge there they're
gonna expect us to be here - I feel like
do you see anybody anymore yeah but
we've got this place online where fell
we're fine I'm just this window makes
why isn't he using those headphones
because I hear I hear his gameplay when
I have those hands on I thought there's
a car okay yeah he's prone oh [ __ ] he's
looking right at us it looks like he's
prone on top of hill [ __ ] I could take a
shot right now should I or no he looks
like he's looking right at us
Oh [ __ ] shoot him are you hitting
should be
what the [ __ ]
it was figuring dirt no I'm hitting him
that was blood what the [ __ ]
lag now there's another guy coming down
the hill from the same spot okay did you
see my screen it looked like I hit him
seven times okay we are not in a circle
now okay
there's guy coming down the hill though
yeah let's ice them what the [ __ ] was
that
it looked like I hit him sit this guy I
don't want to shoot you but actually
hold on did that guy get killed out of
the circle what happened there I have no
idea that's not a bush that was a dude I
watched his face get shot seven times no
one is going to expect you in there well
we have to move now
where's it going down here I guess uh
what do you wanna go through milta let's
go here laughs [ __ ] I would rather stay
away from these hills because I feel
like where do you wanna go what's gonna
get what for now
Mike dude stop the f-bombs I'll try to
stop saying yeah bum - I'm gonna say it
on accident yeah this game is it's it's
amateur game I can swear all right
yellow mature game mature language all
right I'll try stop but I'm not really
worried about that too much
um I don't
let's go to yellow let's move quick
though okay but yeah good call watch
those hills - oh [ __ ] they're in the
building we're going to are they soon
are you I don't think so yeah they're
right in that building the window on the
north side of the house there shoot at
someone else though not at us
yeah [ __ ] should we just go down this
hill to the left yes but go quick cuz
they're in those windows I'm just I'm up
we're gonna be right in the open
it's alright see if we can run to a
2-story house which one 165 it looks
like yeah the circle
yeah using a diode on the circle okay
just uh come over toward that blue roof
barn there could be other people here
just move fast I don't think anybody has
a shot on this right now someone told me
to say Jake you are the best thank you
I'm all right
okay I'm amazed that we are okay so okay
on the hill to directly West we're not
in the circle just move through this
house let's go [ __ ] I'm we're gonna get
ambushed soon
just stick get in a house and then hang
out you gotta get in a circle first yeah
yeah no we're good
watch to our right that's where I saw
someone oh come on yeah we have to cross
the street probably yeah do it
come over here come over here don't
worry the circles not gonna [ __ ] us up
too much right now okay
I'm almost in go behind this camper up
straight ahead all right we're in hold
on just
we got time let's scope it out a little
bit people must have seen us I said
worth even healing I don't think so
no the circle hit me a little tiny bit
you could barely even see it
alright um here I guess yep unless there
are cliffs here we could stick to those
22 other people all right think anyone's
when you come from the east close yeah
yeah yeah looks like behind this green
building green blue they're right on the
edge of the circle
don't don't don't give away until we're
sure we want to do all right there's two
of them yeah I got him they're both here
they're going into that house they don't
know we're here I don't think no they
don't
maker Mike gotta chicken again
yeah I'm yes I've gotten three but
you've I have not gotten one in solo
you're still in this house they might
come running straight yeah yeah they're
gonna have to come out this way cuz the
circle I'm pretty sure we got to move
soon though you want to leave them
behind and go yeah we'll just need to
watch our flank let go quick over here
use this low wall as cover yeah
watch these houses though [ __ ] Oh God
where you at where that I gotta heal up
quick can you cover me I got messed up
yeah damn I don't know where they were
they behind watch behind us I think they
might have been behind us it might've
been those two someone's running around
we gotta move we gotta move okay careful
I'm gonna pop energy jerk really fast
this is this is the end of me so he's
coming from a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they were right next to me those
two came from behind us yeah
oh yeah I don't know who was that the
two behind us there was a guy in a
building I think to the west that was
shooting at us I saw him but it was too
late he was like in a perfect position
let's drop in somewhere where
everybody's dropping this time well
that's what we hoped for with milta
cool man that first shot scared this I
like like I still don't know what
happened with that guy I shot in the
face four times I'm worried I'm worried
that we go back and watch the stream at
just my PC like showing someone there
who was long gone that happen last week
when I headshot punch it all right P
count well how many times we died last
week though well start from this week
yeah we definitely the jump on those two
I didn't I figured I'd let the circle
take care of him though well they didn't
kill me it was guys from yeah ahead of
us oh man
it's got that sound again
sometimes I put that headset on
correctly the reason I don't have it on
is because I would just hear Mike's
audio I got I'll be able to hear my own
is this how you do it yeah that is
that's how I normally do it gamespot you
disappoint me should have gone for those
two you saw you go you know you don't
have to read every single comment
I don't read all of them yeah well you
had the jump on those too
forget it let the circle do it though I
don't feel like walking to the house all
right
are we going
it looks like we're coming from the is
this a night Georgia pull I should be
gonna just do rock let's do rock that's
her
we're the sheriff of Sheriff's is Brock
all right
all right swamp town raawk three two one
anybody else is it's a night
looks like evening switch things up
oh there's a swamp town we just passed
over
looks outside there's a guy right below
us good land on the hills again south
side there's another guy leaning the
south oh there's three guys oh [ __ ] this
is gonna be intense gonna see if I can
land on the roof two storey over here
all right he's right behind me
all right I leaned it on the roof
I'll be over there in a second there's a
guy in here that's not a gun oh my god
he punching someone yeah I headshot dude
you are good at that headshot with a
crowbar
okay I'm hoping I'm just picking up all
these attachments in case you get
something like getting with it now it's
annoying yeah got a scar I'm coming I
don't know where his buddy is all right
I'm coming it's really annoying that you
can't hit like this no one can way are
you still near someone I'm coming over
there he's here but he's like not dead
because I can't hit him with it
there I punched them to death what do
you guys think probably who's trying to
hit me
oh [ __ ] I'll take that if you're not
gonna use it right now fist the enemy
that's what I just did with that other
dude go see it though oh you can pick up
the ump45 or the mp9 where the hell the
other there's like two other guys over
here this worries me are you in there
I'm right next to you I'm gonna come in
I'm right next to him on your right
did you check this building right here I
didn't I wasn't worried about checking
buildings yet doors open oh no I did not
I'm gonna go upstairs and see if I can
see anybody
ice-t was by himself yeah I was waiting
for his body but no one came clearly he
had no friends
give that to time scope yes you want it
yeah you don't mind [ __ ] everybody go
all right two times scope on the ground
right here
do you have any have helped at all yeah
an energy drink I can give you okay all
right I'm going up to the roof maybe I
don't know people gonna be looking there
whatever that is not me shoon oh I see a
little battle going on here we're at
today yeah
no tits you're right that way yeah but
they're gone it looks like see if I can
go around get them I'm really worried
about the north side of this town oh guy
coming down the hill across the street
from you [ __ ] yeah knocked up by a head
shot I'm up on this roof get up here
I'll go to the stairs he hit me with it
easy with a head shot from there I don't
know he must be semi-closed I'm coming
down stairs he might get here before you
but I'm on the stairs the landing on the
stairs be careful they might come up
listen for footsteps footsteps yep yep
yep yep yep damn it
I should have waited I knew you guys
come in I shouldn't have jumped on the
heel [ __ ] ah man
there's a good shot by him with an Uzi
but I also didn't have a helmet or
anything let's do one more
we got time yeah we might we have time
for a couple more yeah depending on how
long we live so far we've not done well
today nope well I got that first guy a
couple times but I did not kill him
our IP count 3 someone said there's a
glitch in the game that if you start
firing wildly into the air you become
invisible for a few seconds it's really
weird Jake try it next time all right at
least I was more interesting the last
one yeah dude that guy Luzi headshot I
should've had to kill you right away
yeah who's best in our office kind of
fluctuates Dave Jewett over in our UK
office is really good he plays a lot at
least
yeah I wanted to get a moltov and test
out that thing but I see no motel just
settings graphics start I think that
one's set for altra yeah but I don't
really like clients to see I don't know
what's up I like it on my desk more one
of my desk runs more smoothly this is
this is a 1080 right yeah it's a 1080
alright
we could go military base I really don't
want to how about this
but [ __ ] we can you wanna yeah alright
we'll make a last one interesting I
would go the military base but we got
one more chance at a assuming we don't
die in like twenty seconds alright per
Tinky is gonna be kind of crazy let's do
it
alright alright jump right over it I
would say alright three your stats after
this my three-to-one sure nope yeah yeah
sure what's my what a my best stats we
were looking than I think duo's is my
best stats in terms of kills wait you
and me have two chicken dinners duo's I
have two squad two duo's I don't have
any solos you have a solo this guy's 25
wins and 13 kills and it's fast
how many 25 wins and 13 kills Dan that's
pretty uh you definitely like to avoid
fight yeah you're conservative that's
good though I mean if you're winning
that much just landed right next to me
I'm gonna get a gun quickly
same oh I see you I know you're there
crossbow it's something one shot all
right that guy was right next to me he's
between us in one of these buildings
does this go outside no I don't know the
layout of this houses I might as well
just take a few bowls all right let's
get some crossbow action I have never
killed anybody with a crossbow there's a
lot of drop yeah I mean it [ __ ] it
doesn't matter gravity is our best
friend here
all right using this house I think and
he's probably got a better gun than oh
he's right now he's coming in he's
coming into your building he's in a red
shirt he's got some kind of weapon rifle
or crossbow I'll be waiting for him I'm
coming in behind him I'll try to he's
right around you really I don't he might
not have come in but he's definitely in
the vicinity come on Oh didn't mean to
pick up that extended mag and still just
a crossbow oh my god I would so much
rather have a handgun because if you
miss you're dead yep still oh [ __ ]
you're farther away that I thought you
were he's in he's coming over that way
but let's just I want to go on some sort
of blaze of glory in this match first
date all right okay all this this stuff
pick up is good in the long term but
right now does not help me at all I
guess I'll take a sickle
nothing come on working boots no one
here - come on where are these guys
throw down in this big building
hold on a second do you see where I am
they're in there I don't know it makes I
saw them hovering around here they might
they look like they went toward you
going in here feeling they might be in
here I'm this big garage building yeah
the doors are open does not mean much
but [ __ ] tons of shotgun what's the
circle we're not too far in the in the
off chance and the chance we get that
far they have to worry about it we're
gonna get that far we're going all the
way to the end Mikey all right still
nothing these doors are all open I wish
I had more than a Cosmo those guys go
[Music]
you still only have a crossbow yeah you
see what I could do with a handgun I'm
not worried if I get a handgun just a
crossbow is all right so they're still
here somewhere
okay that door was closed but all the
other ones are open in here that doesn't
mean anything
oops tears maybe damn it I'm going into
all these the all the buildings between
me and you are looted and I still just
have a crossbow she's probably just
gonna get us that's what I would love to
do still nothing
fire off a warning shot let them know
we're here not kidding I did did you
yeah
no I didn't hear it did you really yeah
did you up that's me I know I know I
know
I'm gonna shoot you if I get bored
enough because I don't know where anyone
else is Jesus your feet slapping the
ground scares me every time I'm gonna
cross this road right here
okay wait yeah go oh [ __ ] am I gonna
make it over this wall there's nothing
worse than just being caught you know
what else is really not fun they're
having a crossbow ah I have a good
feeling about this building Mikey yeah
well makes one of us here's a pistol
thank you that's all I want
I don't think there's ammo sweet
might as well take it so we're gonna
have to move to the circle Adventure oh
look how many people are alive nice
we're gonna have to eventually move
[Music]
what's the best scope you found so far I
haven't found this times 15 I've only
found times eight here's a pistol two
pistols ammo med kit painkiller coming
looks like here's another pistol you
close the door if you don't mind just
cuz yeah maybe you should just pick a
spot in hi that would make for an
interesting stream though would it
I'll go to a 1911 gotta 45 actually
there's way more handle for that Red
Dawn here I'll take that
wait what is this that's the crossbow
still uh we kinda have to move
soonish let me pick out where we're
going to these small buildings I guess
yellow they should get in the circle in
time I feel really safe circle and time
well we'll get in the circle I'm just
saying I'm running into other people all
right I'm gonna go along the side of
this building
I'm god you're so in the open and then
I'd been about to do the same thing have
you won around yet not not on today but
we have we've won two doubles you me of
both wanted two doubles together I've
won a single and then we've we've won a
squad together car right don't yeah
right in front of us but they're going
my god I'm terrified
what's gonna happen in the last two we
win I don't have to fight it out
although I will shoot Mike usually he
dies and I'm gonna do oh my god this is
awful I hate everything happening oh my
god why are you going
how is no one shooting us yet let me let
me take where are you going
going to this building right here I'm
going to yellow care to go up in that
don't don't like try to make this funny
right now
where he's with me I'm coming running no
I'm coming let's do it
Oh God I see him oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right I got my crossbow and a
handgun come out in style oh man I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna get him oh I see
him don't don't you don't don't don't
don't don't don't don't don't don't he
can't see me
looting you Oh where's your partner
oh there he is it's gonna be bad if I
can't hit him you think you heard that
yeah he did
I don't know how to use this thing
let's try again I'll handgun him ran the
face it was here by himself I don't know
let's hope there were two because I
thought one ran in the building the
other came around and kill me from
behind the hell did he go he went up
here yeah I hate crossbows oh there is
take this dude out damn
alright we gotta do one more what's
happening I think he heard the crossbow
I hate him cause bows so much uh alright
we're gonna do one more game hopefully
we do a little bit better this has been
a bust I think what between the two of
us how many kills you think we've gotten
no no if we've got any I got one
there's someone kill rip count quad
thanks Scoob you should stop dying so
much should we land at the school sure
where should we actually there's a
gentleman in Rostock again oh we got a
rainy match you know what they say about
me in the rain crossbows bad luck man
yeah crossbows all right I don't even
know if I was close to him at all when I
shot I don't know how
cuz I don't know
I'm not reviewing this game luckily
chance thps
it was lunchtime I was promised chicken
what the [ __ ]
gube says you know who to blame if you
can't get a kill right scab the luchador
mask Erik Tay yeah all right
does this game play as low for you as
this for me what's that the gameplay is
really low for me maybe it's just I need
revolvers I'm nearly as bad yeah I took
a revolver over
where we gonna jump with [ __ ] again or
here gonna be a few people there it
alright to one drop fast the people
cloud cover
oh god just fell right by me I'm racing
him
big barn there
it's not over yet Rob hand
Oh yep yep yep and they're dropping fast
don't fail though just get after it
there's three other people there's four
other people it's three teams in here
yeah well it's gonna get oh [ __ ] no no
no not in the tree oh god they're gonna
have a gun so much faster than me let's
do it this is not good yeah it is oh
he's got a frying pan I do not I'm out
of here where are you where are you I'm
coming to you know you're okay please
help me he just beat the [ __ ] out of me
with a frying pan oh my god they're
going four guys behind me in those two
houses where are you those two houses
okay well wait wait for me let me get
something this motorcycle and babe yes
where yes I love everything about what
you just said but I need a gun smoke
grenade that'll do
helmet sweet my afros come on police
fast still no health no motorcycle right
here where I'm kinda Hynde me I'm coming
get on it get ready to go no I need some
blood no I need some Bob I'm leaving
without you get on the motorcycle okay
quick Lee go go go go where is okay a
first date is my priority me where
should I be going I'm marked blue go to
blue oh man wait losing the water no
it's not it's if you followed directly
oh there's a boat right there you want
to take the boat no I need first aid
first what is blue just tell me the
water oh this place okay cool yes we're
already in the circle right yeah we're
in the circle
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] here let's go on
the beach now stop stop stop stop I'm
coming back in closer for cover idea
what okay
please if you find first aid I need
anything that I can take that guy beat
the living [ __ ] out of me with a frying
pan I don't even know people watching
where are these gunshots coming from do
you hear this I hear them
[ __ ] yeah shotgun shotgun all right
we're alive dude I ran into this
dead-end earlier when this dude was
chasing me and I had to Juke him he's
still got a punch in his friend probably
called him and said um princess peach
Inge him with a anything anything that I
could use for health I'll take a Clif
Bar at this point no Clif bars in this
game I know I have a smoke grenade a
handgun a shotgun and gasoline this
right here there's nothing up there okay
we're getting bombed we gotta hang out
anyway there were other people in this
town right yeah I heard gunshots
Chad thinks we're dumb cuz we stopped
here oh I don't care at all I'm ready to
[ __ ] throw down yeah let's get out of
here soon okay let's leave I don't wanna
go to milta though so this kids our
inventor of GameSpot uh I'm actually not
credited to inventing GameSpot or
anything for that matter or anything do
you think people are waiting for us oh I
bet you they're no one's moving this
place is getting bombed they just saw me
open this door - I wonder why did you
open the door I want them to come get
out of my way please
hopefully our motorcycles can get blown
to [ __ ] oh damn it
okay you need some help
thanks dr. Decker all right everyone go
I don't wanna go to Milton right now I'm
gonna pop the door open dude ah okay
guys go to the power plant
no that far we could I don't really care
what the circles here and I just want to
heal and get something let's wander to
stick to the coast see what happens
motorcycles go down here
yeah I do let me drive though let me
drive please get off I'm driving no it's
way more interesting no good point fine
you also have okay yeah okay
peace out chip stealthy exit bring that
mic back I'm also just screaming yeah
well we got okay
I almost tipped but this thing is better
at not tipping them oh [ __ ] Jake yeah
it's nice you landed a what's getting
this building quick see if they have
anything I can use
this gas station gas stations usually
don't let's get some get some slim jims
shotgun out can't be too careful
nothing don't even need that night well
I don't know what exactly well let me
have you yeah no oh
got an Uzi that's better than everything
else I have oh don't cubes boy leave my
God heal up wait was that a guy next
thank you so much okay I'm feeling much
better about this can you make sure no
one comes in here blast me in a face
still I'm not feeling great I have a
level two vest and a motorcycle helmet
so my afro is gone which is good
I'm in angle-angle Mike's closer to your
mouth
I don't really care about that all right
here we go
I'm feeling good about this game he's
talking about you Jake all right you're
feeling good about this
can you team kill I don't know yeah we
don't you to it all right let's go we're
at all right I'm just going it's ghost
coastal milta should we just hit no
coast to Milton oh [ __ ] that's the
bridge I'm not going there coast to
milta wait there's a car on the bridge
yeah screw out of here or we could check
out these buildings here someone flipped
a motorcycle right there that's not good
I don't know that stop it until that's
terrifying
let's go right through this is smart no
one ever died like this oh my
all right go straight through milta well
let's stop in milta okay dump here's a
question oh there's a buggy right there
in the middle road there's people here
let's hit some buildings right here hit
some buildings here these buildings
right here okay okay
hit him - OH - I'm not stopping until
these ones these ones are better fine
we'll hit these do you think doors good
look a little Jeep right out here it's
destroyed when we get this let me get
this ready to get out of here not really
much cover where I just put that bike
but we haven't really been smart bus far
so - backpack yeah see yeah this is like
I like this Rough Rider Easy Rider kind
of episode more sweet
pan damn it there's a glitch dad m16
here yeah can I have that no well fine
I'm not giving you oh wait do you really
do you want it ever times for scope okay
Gil my UMP yeah
can I have some actually not ever though
where's the ammo I just dropped it sorry
there you go
hello scar yeah do you want the scar the
m16 you prefer the m16 don't you I
totally do
all right I'll take the scar then thank
you don't five five six seven I took one
but I'm gonna give you the scope why
because I mean no I don't need your ammo
right if you've got a scope sure I threw
it down right here thank you
[Music]
forget what circle looking like right
now they start moving yet it must have
yeah definitely nevermind there's a
meter telling you it did uh did you
check upstairs
yeah nothing oh this is upstairs let's
make sure to close them indoors I know
you are notorious for not doing that
wish we had multiple cameras I do too
maybe we can get it set up one of these
times good hang here and we could go to
yellow and look there just south of us
no it's well let's see where the circle
goes first we've moved around a lot
already
no we're not playing the same account we
are I'm sorry the same stream account
yeah not the render GameSpot account but
we're playing on our own steam accounts
alright but that's not our steam name up
top is it no that's a player unknown do
I have any other first aid no wow I
don't have much in my inventory I like
the rain though just for the ambiance if
nothing else um you're checking these
are the buildings here just hanging out
in that one I was sorting through
inventory stuff but I'll check the other
buildings did you know I like the idea
of thunder kind of well what's is was it
NFL here painkiller sweet was the enemy
at the gates when he timed his shots
with a thunder here's another I'm 16
yeah that's what I said during reboot
that's what yeah right you're right or
that artillery whatever sweet can use
that oh [ __ ] not what I meant to do
lunch nothing in this building okay I
got a good sight any four grips
perchance got a better helmet
AAK actually I'll take that oh yeah I
like tak a lot actually
I just what I won that match with did it
move yet
yeah moved and we're still we go up till
Apopka come on sing with me
finished Luton here lopaka no we could
go to the power plant
where was the plane good question
it was right over lopaka okay the power
plant then sure we're here right across
from it good people just got an a k give
any other sites that you're not using
your no no I'll look for a foregrip
stuff you know what I mean
nothing all right I'm in decent shape
oh this check up here yeah yeah
man I hate these buildings that don't
make sense all right where are we going
Apopka back on the bike oh yeah oh wait
are we going tulip poplar we gonna power
plant sorry power plant around there I
mark a spot across the street cuz where
we put the bike oh yeah toppled over
right by it
well well as we heard a nurse he not
all right don't crash this okay
let me get my bearings my name is low
because mics
I'll turn it up a little bit I'm gonna
yellow right now oh this place looks
awful all right
Apopka no behinds wall is smaller what
if what if someone loads looking right
at this gap in the wall and saw it's
just float by hey I've never been here
before
yeah we have member Nick was obsessed
with the power plan for a while this
isn't the power point those is across
the street I'm talking about this
specific what's the circle doing it
might go to the power plant
like I wouldn't we could hang here for a
little bit um oh you can't get in this
building you can you can't no I don't
know
auto shotgun that looks like the
building this is super-weird reference
but left 4 dead 2 and heavy rain the
episodes thinking that where you make
the halfway point when you come back
from it right before the cornfield in
the gas station but it was also raining
in that because it's called heavy rain
on the way back
all right
[Music]
I'm 36 people it's crazy how you feel I
never really it's crazy how you don't
realize how few people are left
I mean 36 is actually on point for this
size circle but once the circle closes
in we could figure out what to do next I
just said heavy range hard rain sorry
heavy rain was david gage david cage
ethan mars
yes back before those kind of games got
really annoying beyond two souls i don't
know why people are excited for detroit
i think that game looks not fun at all
I'm excited it yeah I like to be on
through souls though I think cyberpunk
would tell a better story well that's
not a weird thing to say everybody
probably thinks that but like cyber
focusing Billie's going for the same
things Deus Ex mankind divided touched
on the same thing
not a whole lot in this building site
building yeah I got that I'm level two
I'm actually not bad aside from a lack
of how many bandages I have 15 but
bandages kind of in a pinch or not that
all right probably don't need the
motorcycle from oh I see a guy you have
to say that they don't see your screen
same here I want to pop you in the face
so bad
is there much in that building
that's a cool building no there's not a
lot but I feel like it is a good
building you can see a lot around you
and I feel like and it's hard to see
people in there too like there's so many
rebar to wait yeah I've never used if
you see seven six - mo let me know are
you using it what do you know using five
five six what's your secondary a shotgun
yeah
if you see seven six - let me know we're
actually in a really good spot for this
circle I could come in there with you
I'm gonna come in there let me get the
bike closer though just in case we need
it
just keep an eye out because I'm gonna
make a little bit of noise now try to
keep it quiet though what never mind I'm
bringing it closer to us and I'm getting
it ready to peal out and go where's the
closest door where'd you go in turn your
left it's like on the left side right
there over here yeah so is this a good
spot for the bike
whoops sorry no way did I get stuck I
don't even think we need it really yeah
I can't help her to have it
ready to go in case okay and I'm sweet
so I will get it ready - I'm just
thinking ahead
yeah we can jump right on if we need it
alright I'm coming in did not shoot me
in the face
I've never been in this building before
neither bye call me and the rain makes
it even more atmospheric
this would be a cool spot for shootout
this reminds me of the construction this
reminds me a lot of things I should shut
up but last thing reminds me the parkour
chase scene in the beginning of Casino
Royale here's another here's another
automatic shotgun and 50 12-gauge shells
I don't even think I must leave now I've
got 25 and I think that's more than
enough
quick draw mcgraw was this extended I
would rather use extended mag because by
the time I empty one clip I'm probably
dead or done I hate we've not seen a
soul since the beginning of this game
yeah but at least it's been whoa whoa
whoa hold on yeah we have you remember
how it started you're right I haven't
killed anyone that's what I meant
anything yeah I haven't died yet I've
you see with your hands I mean this game
there's a malt I guess you want it yeah
I do already have one so I don't need it
I love it too fast it sound like you had
found that already you have one I got my
own pan right here uh see anybody Oh yep
I do
wait where at yeah no I'm almost running
he's running through a field oh yeah I
see him uh another one right behind him
okay I'm a far behind I'm a floor below
you but I've gotten I've got a decent
angle on him let's wait until they come
in here the apartment I've got no angle
I mean like I do have an angle but I've
got no range
I see wait I see one he's going the
other way yeah go around going toward
the center
all right um I know it's gonna happen
this game I'm gonna get lost in here the
circles gonna kill me
all right girls come in who have to move
soon so get ready I'm on the corner over
here looking Southwest
no one has died and like a while I was
at 34 like five minutes ago
oh there we go dontel Leila they just
killed a few people
all right weird circle going damn biker
no no back to Milton oh maybe we should
bike yeah let's do it let's get hold on
let me think this through let's get here
bike here and then move go to yellow
okay but first and most worryingly how
do I get out of this building no I'm
just following you I've just jumped from
this floor here I'm just jumping here we
go all right where was the bike over
here
nope nope nope that is the wrong side we
put the bike over here jeez this
building I am lost at [ __ ] all right I'm
out is the bike there yeah sweet damn I
wish I found 762 in here I actually
wasn't looking that diligently toward
the end
should we bike we have time if you want
to go on foot nah we might not yellow
spike
can I sit through there do you think
I'm going to yellow watch out those
people were running this way yeah I'll
stick toward the bottom of the circle
like usual you say that was that gunshot
gunshots but these yeah I don't think
they were aiming at us actually I've
never been further down oh god oh god
where they I'm sure that and the skinnin
contrived I use these houses coverless
yeah I'm gonna die
sorry good we don't stop we gonna time
gonna stop when you're stopping us up
I'm dead dude there's nothing like
wherever it's gonna stop right in the
middle did you just go into one of those
build oh well but then we would have
been pill I can come oh you're dead I
got dead dead dang that's a [ __ ] way to
end oh it's not over
sorry yeah I don't we had stuck in the
bike walk that we would've been racing
the circle if we didn't like we are I
would have preferred that probably
would've been safe I don't think it's
much what you do
I think he's died yeah I'm mad I died
all right
all right let's see [ __ ]
we dude there's no way we would I could
beat that circle if we took the bike we
would have been full more [ __ ] up
those guys still would have been there
we would have had to contend with that
man the circle I know I'm just mad
because I doggy
you took those bullets for me they would
have hit me if you weren't there [ __ ]
okay this is scary
I need more 762 that would be great yeah
you were just my meat shield
good job soaking up those bullets to
protect Mike Jake so what I'm here for
bullet sponge all right this is gonna
suck Oh what should I do
I guess just sounds like those footsteps
sound more like distant gunshots oh man
I'm gonna get pegged
this will suck [ __ ] there's a guy
I'm gonna go up to stop yeah and I see
him I'm not gonna let him know I'm here
yet
please go prone I don't know probably
this sucks
this is like the worst position yep
[ __ ] I think they stopped I might as
well just keep going I know for a fact
that I'm gonna die soon there's not much
I could do at this point though I just
don't across this dumb field
damn I would be so much farther from
them if these butchers weren't giving me
concealment that got this Ridge coming
up going up a hill to my god this could
not be worse you'll make it
avenge me chicken dinner [ __ ] do I go
now
those trees where'd those two guys go
idea I just gotta go they're gonna start
with the pot shots - oh I'm I get
nauseous when this is happening and
where do they rock is the rock in the
circle tea right no no at least it gives
me cover from behind those two Co that's
scared yeah yeah I'm also going up this
hill okay this is where it gets
terrifying cuz oh there's a rock right
there but someone's got to be there
already the chat is for you Mike you got
this they say watch out for the circle
yeah I'm good I think you might get
dinged by it that's all right I don't
care at this point
[ __ ] circle [ __ ] you I'll have to go
any farther this rock right here at
least I've got time behind those guys we
didn't seem wrong the hill they gotta be
dead or they've got to be dying see
that's what worries me I don't want to
go [ __ ] oh wait hold on what don't don't
listen to me do it you think what do I
do
there's a rock here do you think they're
people somebody's got to knocked out
with a car someone posted up with a car
in their car 98 oh man
which side do I come in from the east
I'm trying member what the circle did
initially I have no idea I would get up
by this rock oh you have to move never
money can't I mean the thing if you come
by the east at least the circle move
slower
yeah that's I'm thinking from this angle
but be careful of these two houses to
your right yeah well that's one aiming
for right now that dudes still knocked
out he didn't kill that last dude it's
still eight alive dude I don't have time
for this [ __ ] there's got to be someone
in this house right
which side do I go on this side circle
take longer but those guys are down
there if they didn't die yet you see
anyone I don't see anyone do you have a
circles coming you have a energy drink
you can pop yeah but I'm just gonna get
by this rock quick there's a guy in this
house I doubt it
my innocent circle and my enemies in the
circle circle [ __ ] you guys to your left
how am I not in yet you're in your good
why is the line still tell me I'm not
cuz it's about to move again do you
don't have much you don't need much dude
where's that guy with the car 98
probably to your right or that dude that
dude with the that's the dude that's
been killing a ton of people I've seen
his name pop up like nine times so I go
Auto with this or what burst oh I don't
know I don't do more I mean the aka is
more damage to it
I just gotta wait right now so what
there's two T there's one team and one
guy left one team and then one guy by
himself ooh
throwing a grenade yeah well do
something [ __ ] I've gotta go stick to
this grass I'm gonna have to get up and
die three left it's probably one team oh
the other guy died that's two guys in
the car though car 98 damn is he in that
Shack owner if it's a team or if it's
yeah that will suck I see one oh let him
go in I don't think it's the team
they're gonna see me in a second I'm in
the grass I'm gonna Kevin
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all right damn it oh the
other guys in that Shack dude that guy
in the shacks gotta win one more game
you know that's enough for me I'm uh
I got wrong that last game the way who
won the guy that killed me I don't know
I can't tell ya you took bullets for me
ah all right I think that's all we got
for today however we will be back next
week with more pub G most likely yeah
hopefully we'll do better yeah today it
was a little bit rough except for that
last game you do pretty well and then
make sure to check out reboot and if you
enjoyed this make sure to subscribe
really helps us out
anything else no that is it kind of
shaking right now so dammit he was right
next to me I sure look to my right and
then I would have been up against that
guy in the shack oh man can't linger on
it alright thanks for joining everyone
see you guys thank you